good morning Hank it's Wednesday so I
just watched a video by nerdfighter such
ducks in which she claims that we don't
make as many inside jokes as we used to
I don't know what to do about that Hank
except maybe to reveal for the second
time in human history the pizza John
moustache that's right Hank the pizza
John moustache is like herpes and the
Transformers franchise you can never be
quite sure that it's gone away for good
but Hank I suspect that even this is not
enough to satisfy such duck so I shall
wear my pizza mustache while eating
pizza I'm flying the thriller Hegel and
then I'll go for a walk with my puppy
sized elephant and the dread pirate
fireball Wilson Roberts and French the
llama while wearing a book called tender
morsels in your pants on my head you
didn't do the hand thing what's the hand
thing you didn't do the hand thing I've
been doing it the entire time with my
right hand go back and watch so Hank is
you sorry I'm having a really hard time
taking myself seriously right now uh I
feel like it looked like both a cop and
a creeper Hank so like I feel like I
should be arresting myself for creepin
in the first degree right but anyway hey
cuz I'm sure you're aware there's been a
lot of conversation on tumblr and the
Ning and YouTube and Twitter about
nerdfighteria changing as it grows and
how to keep the community strong and etc
and I just thought I would throw in my
two cents but first I just want to
establish two rules not just for
nerdfighteria but also for like general
human existence number one don't be mean
and number two dftba
Hank I know those rules are hard to
follow but they are the rules and if you
break them the half of my mustache that
as a cop will arrest you and the half of
my mustache that is a creeper will get
creepy I can't look at myself in the
viewfinder Hank I can't take myself
seriously I have got to get rid of this
mouth caterpillar ah so much better
alrighty first I want to remind
everybody that nerdfighter II has
accomplished a ton in the last few
months we've raised more than $10,000
with Esther for this star won't go out
the project for awesome generated more
than six hundred thousand comments and
raised more than 150 thousand dollars
we've broken the email inbox of Warner
Chilcott CEO determined that moon pasta
is more efficient than the earth beef
transcribed every single vlogbrothers
video at nerdfighteria info and
nerdfighters continue to do amazing
things all over the world from dressing
up as Phineas Gage for Halloween to
drawing regular squids of rational
debate and source citation to attending
anything but clothes parties while my
face stares at you creepily from the
closet that's it
right area definitely needs better ways
to interact like YouTube comments are
awesome but they don't really lend
themselves to building relationships or
making stuff collaboratively and the
Ning is also awesome but can be very
confusing particularly to new users and
Hank Ning masters are working on that
but in the meantime some nerdfighters
are building your pants Hank I'm sure
you remember that the original
Brotherhood 2.0 form was called my pants
well this is going to be like my pants
except yours so hopefully in the next
week or so your pants will be live it's
going to be a great place to build
friendships and decrease worldsuck and
make nerd fight astok things so keep
watch it'll be at your pants dot-org not
your pants comm if you go to your pants
comm Google will tell you that they
can't find your pants which I mean I
don't expect you to be able to find my
pants Google that's my job
Google your job is when I input a
symptom you tell me what terrible
disease I probably have all right here's
the last thing I want to say about nerd
fighting incivility no one can tell you
if you're a nerdfighter and you can't
tell anyone else if they're a
nerdfighter nerdfighter is an identity
you choose and then we collectively
define that identity not by talking
about what it means but by living it and
in my opinion that goes for almost all
identities from the ones we choose like
musician or rider to the ones that seem
unchosen like brother identities are
important but both the ones you choose
and the ones that choose you generally
resist simple definitions I mean Hank if
I've learned anything about Brotherhood
in the last four years it's that
Brotherhood is about a hell of a lot
more than sharing the same parental
units Hank I'll see you on Friday and
nerdfighters starting next week I'll see
you in your pants sorry I had to bring
the mustache back for that one movie
magic